so today I'm going to talk about the
number one danger of prolong fasting
okay and that danger would be this you
die okay I mean unfortunately you can't
fast forever right at some point you're
going to run out of fat Fuel and you're
going to run out of muscle and organ
fuel because that is what happens after
you do fasting it turns into starvation
once the muscles are being consumed for
calories and then there'll be a point
where you just die however that's not
going to happen to you because I'm going
to show you exactly how to do this
because on the flip side there's no
other action that you can do to create
more Health than prolonged fasting so
I'm going to show you how to do this
safely a couple other problems with
fasting that people run into is that
they may lose some muscle okay or they
may create nutritional deficiencies
because the purpose of eating is to not
just get fuel but to also supply all
your nutrients however that's a really
simple problem to overcome if you know
what nutrients to take but in this video
I want to talk more about
protein and specifically muscle protein
how to prevent the loss of your muscle
while you do prolonged fasting the
question is how do we get the benefits
of improved immune system or getting rid
of cancer if we have cancer or
strengthening our brain getting more
cognitive function in elevated mood
improvements and getting rid of
inflammatory conditions and degenerative
conditions as well as extending our life
and how do we do all that and retain our
muscle protein now the first thing you
need to know is that the fatter you are
the longer you have the ability to eat
yourself and I'm talking about eating up
your fat your reserves when you're doing
prolonged fasting you are living off
your body tissue specifically adipose
tissue and the more of that you have the
law longer you can fast without any
problems unfortunately especially with
people that have cancer that really want
to do prolonged fasting for like 20 days
or even 30 days if they don't have
enough fat it becomes very difficult
however I'm going to show you what I'm
going to recommend and today we're just
going to answer a lot of questions one
question I'm just going to handle right
from the very beginning is can you gain
muscle while you're doing fasting
fasting is not the best strategy for
building up your muscle mass okay
chances are you're not going to build
too much muscle when you're fasting even
no growth hormone is going way up
because muscle growth is a reflection of
more calories as well as exercise and so
if you're eating no calories it's going
to be very difficult to increase muscle
mass however I'm more interested in
preserving muscle mass okay and a couple
things you need to know about preserving
your muscle number one the more you are
into ketosis the less muscle you're
going to break down so ketones prevent
the breakdown of muscle tissue that's
one thing the other thing that happens
when you do fasting is you really Spike
growth hormone and growth hormone also
spares your muscle okay it prevents the
loss of muscle muscle preservation is a
Survival action so your body wants to
preserve muscle so it will go after
other things first and so this is a
perfect bridge to this topic of
autophagy autophagy is a condition in
your body where your body is recycling
old damaged proteins throughout the body
okay
your muscles not just protein in fact
every single cell in your body contains
some protein you have skin intestines
fascia connective tissue all of that is
protein and when you do prolong fasting
you trigger autophagy and so you're
getting this recycling of this damaged
protein into new amino acids so there's
a lot of benefits from autophagy and one
being getting rid of pathogens so if you
have viruses in your body that are just
kind of lingering around your body will
take care of those and get rid of those
and so people have a concern about their
muscles being eaten up from autophagy
but you have to realize that like I said
before all cells are made from protein
skin intestines and so your muscles
actually are going to be dining off of
your skin cells and intestine cells the
damaged skin cells the damage connective
tissue cells maybe scar tissue that you
had or all of this damage protein will
be fed to your muscle before your muscle
gives up its amino acids which is a
really cool thing now as long as you
have enough fat your body is not going
to tap into the muscle reserve of any
significant amount this video is not
really about intermittent fasting this
is about prolonged fasting so you're
fasting uh three days five days seven
days two weeks a month okay the question
is how do we make sure that we preserve
a muscle especially if you are going in
to this prolonged fasting with atrophy
okay let's say you're menopausal and
some of your muscles are atrophied okay
which looks very very similar to fat and
you start doing long-term fasting how do
you deal with that because some of that
muscle is also damaged now this is what
I recommend
autophagy is inhibited by eating and
eating protein especially okay but it
goes on like a gradient type thing right
so when you start eating less than a
thousand calories a day you'll start
triggering autophagy to a certain degree
and the last that you eat the more
autophagy you're going to trigger so it
really has to do with quantity or
amounts of calories and so you can
induce autophagy or get the benefits
even doing a low calorie type diet it's
called calorie restriction okay you can
do that but of course you're going to
get a little bit more benefits if you're
doing just straight fasting with no
calories for the first two or three days
okay 48 to 72 hours I'm going to
recommend not taking any type of protein
or amino acid supplements however
at the fourth day of fasting you
introduce amino acids and here's why
amino acids are the building blocks of
protein and so by taking straight amino
acids it gives your body this already
broken down building block that your
tissues can start to use immediately
your liver doesn't have to work to break
it down and when you take amino acids
there's very little calories okay but
when you start the prolonged fasting if
you allow the body to clean up a lot of
the old damaged proteins which then add
the amino acids let's say the fourth day
and then you start taking amino acids
after that you are consuming something
that's very low calorie your muscles can
then utilize these amino acids and the
other tissues can utilize these amino
acids to prevent fatigue and to prevent
any type of loss of any protein tissue
from there on out and at the same time
get all these wonderful benefits the
type of amino acid blend that I'm going
to recommend I put a link down below low
because this specific blend has been
proven to be very effective and it does
not turn into sugar like a lot of other
collagen type products or protein
products do so in other words you want
to use an amino acid blend that is very
very balanced the next question is
should you exercise or not well this all
depends again on how much fat that you
have as your reserve and also it depends
on how adapted you are to fat when you
start ketosis and you're new to it you
can be in ketosis within two or three
days okay but to be really fat adapted
that takes more like a month to three
months okay where you are just burning
fat like a machine when your body is in
that situation you can handle a heavier
workout a more intense workout because
when you work out you're going to be
tapping into fat not just your sugar
reserves your glycogen in your muscle
and your liver in which you would run
out really quickly and then get really
tired so the more adapted you are the
more you're going to maintain your
energy while exercising and exercise as
itself is a very potent stimulus of
autophagy and so you'll get a lot more
benefits if you combine the exercise
with prolonged fasting
but if you're not fully adapted long
walks would be totally fine and
something I would recommend and then the
next question is supplements what type
of supplements should you be taking well
this is the list right here electrolytes
okay electrolyte powder make sure you
have electrolytes with enough potassium
because our buys require a lot of it the
B vitamins are very very important you
may want to take nutritional yeast
unfortified because that gives you the
natural form of B vitamins sea salt very
important no less than one teaspoon a
day a lot of people do not consume
enough sea salt and you're going to feel
very weak when you do this process
especially your muscles because of the
sodium that's required that go along
with these other electrolytes like
potassium you might want to take vitamin
D better yet get sun if you can if you
can't take vitamin D simply because even
though it's a fat soluble vitamin so
many people are deficient in vitamin D
going into it and so fasting tends to
aggravate this deficiency the other
thing I'm going to recommend is omega-3
fatty acids a good source would be cod
liver oil because cod liver oil not only
has
omega-3 fatty acids but it also has
vitamin d as well as Vitamin A so you
can actually kill three birds with one
stone I would also recommend a natural
source of vitamin C and vitamin E if
you're doing like maybe a week of
fasting or longer just because those are
two other vitamins like the water
soluble vitamin C that's going to go
through your body pretty quick and we
don't want you to start ending up with
vitamin C deficiencies as well as
Vitamin E deficiencies and this way
you'll maintain your strength you'll
prevent nutritional deficiencies you'll
be able to even exercise and you'll be
able to get the benefits of weight loss
too and look healthy as you lose weight
as well as all the internal benefits
that are occurring with this prolonged
fast now one last point about cancer
if you have cancer and you're doing this
I would try to go longer without taking
the amino acids simply because there are
certain amino acids that can feed the
cancer so if you do a straight fast
without the amino acids I think you'll
benefit greatly unless you have certain
symptoms like significant muscle loss
things like that but overall I would
rather lose more weight and be very very
skinny and get rid of the cancer then be
focused on you know preventing that
weight loss and end up dying from cancer
prolonged fasting is hands down the best
strategy of getting rid of cancer if you
have cancer even if it's stage four I've
done videos on this so realize that any
negative effects from fasting don't even
come close to the benefits of doing
fasting for cancer now I have another
video on the details of how to do
prolonged fasting and what to eat after
you stop fasting and check it out I put
it up right here